[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com so we need to have just like
a very real and honest conversation
today about the reality that Donald
Trump just always gets his ass kicked
internationally by everyone and I don't
like it and I want to know whether you
see it my way and whether this is
something you're concerned about and I'm
not talking about any kind of delusional
my framework for this is not some hyper
nationalist
the US needs to always come out quote
winning at the expense of every other
country I want us working together with
the international community I want to
solve serious problems in productive
ways as as an alliance of countries but
what I mean is why is it that Donald
Trump is always the loser in
negotiations often negotiations he
shouldn't be participating in always the
laughingstock always the guy that the
adults in the room often aren't even
inviting into the room anymore because
his presence is so pointless and
counterproductive that's what I want to
talk about today it is embarrassing
that the president can't stop getting
his ass kicked
day in and day out it's it's boneheaded
stupidity and I'm gonna give you some
examples there's lots of good ones by
the way
in a recent DailyKos piece which I
recommend you check out by Lawrence
Lewis which was posted to our subreddit
Donald Trump as an example is now
considering jumping into a fifteen
billion dollar french bailout of Iran if
Iran is willing to come back into the
Iran nuclear deal a be back in
compliance with the Iran nuclear deal
there are people so out of touch with
reality that they see this as Donald
Trump being the big strong negotiator
but this is maybe the most ignorant ly
myopic view of Internet
national relations and specifically of
the Iran deal than I can imagine
remember Donald Trump bailed out of the
Iran nuclear deal
even though Iran had been in compliance
ever since the deal was signed it was an
international embarrassment for the
United States to just not stick to our
agreements without anyone else having
violated them why would we not stick to
our side of the deal the other countries
including France had to try at the g7 to
salvage what was potentially left and
one of the things that they said was
okay if the u.s. is out we get that it's
logical that you might try to start
researching nuclear technology and
developing it and it could potentially
be used for weapons what can we do to
keep you in compliance and one of the
things they came up with was a $15
French a 15 billion dollar French
bailout which now Donald Trump is
considering participating in because he
wants Iran to be compliant with the
nuclear deal this is only a conversation
this is only on the table because Trump
bailed on the nuke deal to begin with
for no reason whatsoever just getting
his ass kicked
getting it kicked internationally
another obvious example is North Korea
we're going to talk more about North
Korea later on in today's program Trump
is so desperate to be liked and so
overconfident in his negotiating skills
that he doesn't even realize that
there's this long history of North
Korean leaders manipulating the United
States are trying to manipulate the
United States and Trump goes and meets
with Kim jong-un no preconditions pranic
plenty of pompous bluster comes out
thinking that he negotiated some
incredible deal that no one else has
been able to do even though it was the
same promises that the Kim family has
been making for decades claims victory
and then of course nothing happens and
meanwhile North Korea nuclear and
weapons development just keeps going on
ballistics missiles missile tests Trump
getting his ass kicked internationally
again one more example I think you're
getting the sort of gist of it the
Chinese trade war Trump thinks I'll
throw some tariffs at China they'll
buckle down the US will win
ever he defines that never mind that he
doesn't even understand how tariffs work
he doesn't understand how the us-china
relationship works and China instead
says okay you're putting tariffs on us
we'll put tariffs on you we'll get our
aluminum and our steel elsewhere we'll
make a deal with Russia for energy
development and exploration we'll get
our soy elsewhere and Trump gets his ass
kicked again
crushing farmers crushing related
industries and the world is just
wondering what is this guy doing why is
he doing this could we maybe not have a
president getting his ass kicked weekly
and I've been very careful when I make a
comparison between Trump and George W
Bush I don't want to do it in any way
that suggests George W Bush was anything
other than a neoconservative maniac with
terrible policies Bush didn't get his
ass kicked in this way internationally
week in and week out Bush made terrible
policy decisions I disagreed with his
moral framework based on born-again
Christianity or whatever it was that he
most recently ascribed to he was a war
monger economically I didn't agree with
the guy but he wasn't getting his ass
kicked in the boneheaded way that Donald
Trump is week in and week out our
historical allies are looking around
wondering what's wrong with this guy
it's not just that they disagree with
the decisions or the underlying policy
to the extent Trump has an underlying
political philosophy they just can't
understand why he keeps doing the most
boneheaded things to his own
disadvantage and it's reflecting
extremely poorly on the United States
the world you know the the Trump may
have high approval among red-state
Republicans 55-plus I'm sure among that
group his approval rating is off the
chart but the world is wondering how
could Americans be so dumb and this is
the way they're thinking about us now
how could they be so dumb as to have
voted this guy in in the first place we
need to change that in November of next
year and I hope that we will hey this is
pretty funny
not only does British Prime Minister
Boris Johnson look like Donald Trump
he's also triggered just as easily by
people who disagree with him were very
quickly learning we've been covering the
atrocious idea
that is brexit since the vote back in
June June 23rd of 2016 I believe it was
and whether brexit will or won't
ultimately happen we still don't know
although it's not looking particularly
good but in any case one of the most
recent sort of milestones or events in
the brexit saga was the abandonment of
the prime ministership by Teresa May and
her replacement by the pro brexit
conservative Boris Johnson who looks a
lot like Trump and we're learning his
trumpian in some other ways and things
have not been going particularly well
for Boris Johnson between abandonment of
the Tory Party by one MP combined with a
number of others just not agreeing with
Boris Johnson's path forward on brexit
he is managing a brexit that is once
again very much imperiled and
increasingly unpopular yesterday Boris
Johnson was in Luxembourg and he was
scheduled to do a press conference with
the prime minister of Luxembourg and
this is amazing they come out of this
meeting and there are two lecterns and
two microphones set up for them and
there's a lot of protests that have got
protesters rather that have gathered in
Luxembourg and the prime minister of
Luxembourg ends up just walking Boris
Johnson straight out Boris Johnson just
completely bails on this press
conference they had scheduled and then
around comes the Luxembourg prime
minister and actually does a little bit
of a press conference by himself check
this out we're gonna have video here of
Johnson walking out with the Luxembourg
Prime Minister and just walking right on
by the lectern and straight out as a
result of the protesters and then the
prime minister of Luxembourg comes back
around it actually talks to the press
show this is live pictures as Boris
Johnson leaves the Luxembourg on his
arrest and says just listening
well you can hear the noise that awaited
his departure and that has led to the
cancellation of the news conference that
was scheduled for 250 is happening as
the camera goes on you see to the left
there the podium where they'd - promises
would have held that news conference but
because of the noise and booing and the
use of a megaphone chants from many
British expats among them Berto with
banners testing boys Breton fetch I
think through your mail here from the
locks book on Easter right now so let's
just let's just listen in
[Music]
thank you very much for listening to me
I think demonstrating is a right in a
democracy and it is important also to be
able to exchange and to listen to each
other this is just amazing first of all
how funny is it that Xavier Battelle the
Luxembourg Prime Minister walks out with
Boris Johnson like clearly Boris Johnson
is fine they had their meeting they walk
right by where the press conference was
supposed to taking place walks him right
out and then goes over to the lectern
and immediately people quiet
right down and he's able to talk with
with no problem whatsoever and the
hilarious explanation from Boris
Johnson's team was that it was just too
loud and rambunctious because of those
protesters rambunctious being my word
not theirs admittedly and that it would
just be really hard for anybody to hear
him if he participated in in this press
conference and yet it seems like it was
fine and he would obviously have been
given the opportunity to speak what a
brave guy right at Trump wouldn't go to
Britain
unless Britain could guarantee that
protests would be quashed and Trump
wouldn't have to be driving around met
by protesters and then you've got
British Trumpy and British Prime
Minister Boris Johnson going to
Luxembourg and just straight up walking
away from the press conference without
participating and there's a very
interesting parallel sort of developing
between Trump and Johnson other than as
I've said they have a very similar look
physically they're both triggered by
protesters very easily
they both are increasingly not respected
by other world leaders almost every
world leader other than I guess you know
some of the authoritarian types I guess
like Trump or I don't know if respect
Trump is the right word but most world
leaders don't respect the President of
the United the current President of the
United States fellow European Union
leaders increasingly don't respect Boris
Johnson and his harebrained ideas so
what hopefully this represents and we
may see starting to see the pendulum
sort of swing back against the
nationalist authoritarian ideas that
have been sort of successfully
masquerading as populism over the last
four to five years it's become trendy in
some circles hopefully we're starting to
see the pendulums
going back the other way one other
similarity I'm seeing between Trump and
Boris Johnson is that the United Kingdom
is increasingly seen as a laughingstock
internationally as a result of the
endless brexit Fiasco much like the
United States under Donald Trump is also
seen as a complete and total
laughingstock it it's actually quite
remarkable the similarities that have
developed between the United States and
the UK over the last couple of years
we'll continue to follow brexit will
continue to follow Boris Johnson and the
ways in which he is increasingly similar
to the President of the United States
let me know what you think about him
just bailing walking right by the
lectern and going on out and back to
Britain I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on twitter at david pakman show
and make sure that you are following me
on twitch at twitch.tv slash David
Pakman if you have an Amazon Prime
membership already at no extra cost you
can subscribe to our twitch channel with
something called twitch Prime Amazon
Prime confers one free twitch Prime
membership per month costs you nothing
but it counts as a paid membership for
us it's like free money that you can
give us at twitch.tv slash David Pakman
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new members of the
day are florian boots and glenn collins
florian and glenn really appreciate your
support membership is the primary
funding source for our show you can sign
up in under a minute at join pakman.com
today's long time sustaining member of
the day is dale brooks tails been with
us for almost five years every year you
stay a member we get even stronger much
to the dismay of those who are waiting
for the show to fail and there are many
of them unfortunately join these great
folks by signing up at join pakman.com
we do have a 40% off coupon code
available but not mandatory that code is
this is 20/20 and it'll save you 40% off
of the membership of your choice so
Donald Trump's taxes are back in the
news and have actually been subpoenaed
by the Manhattan district attorney state
prosecutors in Manhattan have subpoenaed
Donald Trump's accounting firm demanding
eight years of both Trump's personal and
business tax returns now the first
question we might ask is district
attorney if a district attorney is
issuing a subpoena for Donald Trump's
tax returns is this related to some kind
of investigation and the answer is that
yes it turns out that at the end of
August a criminal investigation was
opened up into those hush money payments
made by Donald Trump to mistresses and I
know many of us are completely fatigued
and sick of this hush money thing by now
and I'll sort of address that in a
second these are the payments that were
made the payments were made in a in a
literal sense by trumps now in prison
personal attorney Michael Cohen but of
course they were made in service to
Donald Trump and Donald Trump as far as
we know reimbursed those payments to
Michael Cohen so that's the answer to
question one it's part of that
investment a criminal investigation
question two is what's the full scope of
this Manhattan district attorney probe
is it related only to the 2016 hush
payments or is there some broader
campaign finance or other investigation
that this is part of we don't know the
answer to that we know that one legal
question about the hush money
particularly the payment made to stormy
Daniels is did Donald Trump's business
call that a legal expense in their
accounting which would be number one
hilarious and number two potentially
illegal and a felony if it was done to
conceal some other crime like tax
evasion or bank fraud or in the service
of some additional crime so we'll figure
that out maybe someday but let's get
more to what matters here and what
doesn't matter I understand we are
mostly sick of this entire hush money
payment thing the hush money payments
themselves as a way to punish Donald
Trump or make him suffer consequences
for the things that he did I believe
that that ship has sailed we can as a
practical matter vote Donald Trump out
way faster than the hush money payment
investigation could even potentially
remove him from office it's just not
going to happen we shouldn't even be
thinking about that then we get to the
content of the tax returns themselves
that's actually what we're interested in
now that being said this is a district
attorney subpoena for an investigation
if they get the tax returns meaning if
the grand jury gets those tax returns
they would not even go public unless
they're leaked of course unless they end
up becoming evidence at a trial that is
also extremely unlikely to happen so I
don't really see this as something to be
optimistic about in terms of the
material getting to us for our review
but it's yet another thing that could
trigger Donald Trump first of all
secondly every time that we do hear
anything related to the content of
Donald Trump's taxes it's been something
that makes him look terrible so there is
still the potential here that if any of
this is released in any way leaked or
otherwise it's going to contain
extremely damaging information about
Donald Trump remember that when the
summaries of Donald Trump's tax returns
got out we learned that he lost just
like insane amounts of money and they
put out his attorney or someone put out
a stay
and saying oh this is all calculated you
know he's gaming the system and this is
all because he's such a great
businessman people who were not working
for Trump who know about tax law and
accounting looked at it and said no no
no this is just the guys really losing a
lot a lot of money or he lost a lot of
money in that time it would not be for
the tax benefit we also learned from
other tax disclosures of Trump that we
got a while ago that Donald Trump's dad
had financed a lot of Donald Trump's
failures we call that Rich Dad bails me
out just like the height of privilege
for someone claiming to be a self-made
man so this could be interesting if
something like that comes out it could
be interesting in that even just
fighting it could become a big story and
expensive for Donald Trump which would
be just delightful but as far as getting
rid of Trump as far as exposing
criminality the strategy remains the
same one that it's been for more than a
year vote Trump out in November of 2020
he'll be gone when a new president is
inaugurated in January of 2021 and it
will be far far more efficient than any
of these ideas related to tax returns or
the 25th amendment or impeachment I know
the fans of each of those individually
will say no those are great ideas David
and they may well be but they're not
going to get Trump out any faster than
just voting him out in November if you
disagree with me let me know Donald
Trump is trying to go after the Hispanic
vote increasingly we know that he has
said he loves his african-americans as
he has pointed to people in the crowd by
the way the guy he referred to as my
african-american he I guess is no longer
a Republican so that didn't go super
well and Donald Trump now trying to
appeal to Hispanic and Latino voters
Trump did a campaign rally yesterday in
New Mexico the idea was let's show up
there and let's talk about how low
Hispanic unemployment is and how great
everything is and it went about as
poorly as you would expect
first of all bad poll after bad poll for
Donald Trump in some key swing states
for 2020 eight years of tax returns
subpoenaed as I already told you about
new corruption investigation into
Trump's Transportation Secretary who
happens to be Mitch McConnell's wife
Elaine Chao so Trump in the midst of all
this shows up in New Mexico and tries to
appeal to Hispanic voters
sort of in the same way that he tried to
appeal to black voters in 2016 which is
blaming other people for things and
citing incorrect statistics the clips
are genuinely hard to watch but also
kind of fun listen to Trump here as he
talks about the Hispanics as he refers
to them by so where the Hispanic
American the Hispanics were up with me
in a poll 17% and everyone said how is
that up by 70 I won't even tell you what
the final number was because they won't
believe it
but you're gonna see what the final
number but you know why because the
Hispanic Americans they understand they
don't want criminals coming across the
border they don't want people taking
their jobs they want to have that
security and they want the wall they
want the wall taking their jobs it's
truly hilarious that they still use that
stupid debunked bogus talking point
meant to completely exculpate big
corporations from the immigration low
wage status quo that persists here in
the United States and more importantly
the bigger lie there Donald Trump
claiming that Hispanics want the border
wall it's like no they don't most of the
country doesn't want the border wall and
if you're looking specifically at
Hispanic voters they we I should say as
part of that group we don't want the
border wall I mean completely and
totally untrue Trump also heckled
yesterday a bunch of times I was only
able in the time I had to prep this
morning I was only able to pull one clip
where you hear the heckling going on
Trump doing all the normal attempts to
attempt to appeal to Hispanic voters
you'll hear him getting heckled after
the initial applause line here in the
background Trump just continues talking
over it and actually does successfully
yesterday marked the beginning of the
Hispanic Heritage Month who is Hispanic
Latinos fitrah
credible people but we have much to
celebrate unbelievable when you think
the unemployment for Hispanic Americans
is right now at the lowest level ever
recorded in the history of our country
Hispanic American poverty reached a
brand-new all-time low in history and
after years of stagnation that you know
very well wages for Hispanic Americans
are rising really fast up nearly 8
percent since my election those are
unheard of numbers and medium income
think of that median income for Hispanic
Americans surpassed fifty thousand
dollars for the first time ever so this
is the same type of pandering that we've
seen from Donald Trump before yes the
polls don't look good among Hispanics
for Donald Trump or in these swing
states but the only poll that matters in
the end is how people actually go and
vote in November of 2020 if they
actually choose to vote so despite all
this pandering despite all this rambling
and all of it that man that you just saw
talking about Hispanics and lying about
the wall he can still win in 2020 on
autopilot if we do not show up how a
Hispanic voter speaking as a Hispanic
voter myself can support Donald Trump at
this point I don't know and the rallies
make it even more confusing patronizing
marginalized and minority communities in
the most obviously transparent ways the
supporters are totally cringe worthy
it's an international embarrassment and
it actually in the end may all work to
get the guy reelected that's just the
the sole focus needs to be no matter how
cartoonish the clips I play for you no
matter how unbelievable and erratic and
and bogus are the claims that Donald
Trump makes he can get reelected in 2020
and he can do it even if his approval
rating drops 10 points mathematically
that is and so in the end all that
matters is that we actually go and vote
in November of 2020 and get as many
people as possible to go and do the same
thing make sure you're following the
David Pakman show on instagram at david
pakman show and while you are there
follow me on instagram at david pakman
we'll take a quick break and back with
oliver thorn from philosophy - right
after this the david pakman show at
david pakman.com welcome back to the
david pakman show it's great to welcome
to the program today Oliver thorn who's
a professional actor and also the
creator of philosophy 2 of a youtube
channel with about half a million
subscribers teaching philosophy in fun
interesting and I would say
well-produced ways is that is that fair
to say
oh thank you that's very kind of you
it's a pleasure to be here so I mean let
for people not familiar with you to talk
a little bit about the the philosophy
piece of it I mean how long have you
been studying philosophy and sort of
like what's your relationship generally
to philosophy it was my first degree and
I started the show in my second year of
university I just wanted to give away my
degree for free online that was six
years ago and since then it's become
phenomenon I guess one of the things I
like about what you do is that there's a
movement at least in the United States
where the right will often successfully
convert people to their side by talking
exclusively about principles and I've
long said that it's great to understand
what our principles are and to be
introspective and so on and so forth but
that a lot of the dirty work or the work
happens in actually figuring out how to
apply those principles to real world
problems and very quickly realizing that
oftentimes those principles conflict one
thing I think you do well and I'm
curious to hear whether this is
deliberate or one of the primary things
you're trying to do is integrate the
discussions of principles from the
get-go into how they relate to real
world problems and not have this
separation of all that matters is the
principles which which sometimes happens
with philosophical discussions yeah
definitely I always try to make the
philosophy relevant to everyday life I
mean that's that's half the fun and
that's half of what I try and do is say
no this isn't just some sort of ivory
tower academic like a beige druggie
thing like philosophy isn't relevant to
people's lives I think if that's the way
you're doing philosophy then I think
arguably you're doing it wrong the whole
point is that it's it's sometimes life
and death and it's vitally interesting
and and is so interesting and important
if you give it a chance so yes
absolutely trying to do that separately
are you trying to reorient people's
values or perspectives is that or how
would you how would you describe like
the goals of what you are doing is it
education does do you consider that it
goes beyond that into advocacy I think
it's definitely educational I also try
and take a bit of a new approach to
education
I find that certainly they're not
exclusively on the right often when
people talk about philosophy and
principles in education it's very
competitive it's like you need this so
you can win or you need this to be like
aggressive the analogy that I use is
like imagine if people only went to the
gym because they were training to be
street fighters it's like this is kind
of weird way of doing it was what I try
and do is create an environment where
it's not competitive it's not about like
boning the libs or like winning the
debate it's about the curiosity not
ambition is the mantra that I that I try
and use so yes it's educational but also
I've got a kind of meta educational
attitude towards it which I try and
bring across in my work as well have you
heard anecdotally about people whose
worldview or at least their views on
particular issues have been drastically
altered by consuming your content yeah
big time I get emails almost every day
from people who say that which is
amazing and what's the gist of it in the
sense of I mean I guess I have many
questions about this feel free to pick
any of these that you want to address
first I mean are you seeing what is the
ideological change that seems to most
commonly be taking place what is it
specifically that people say it was that
changed their minds I got a lot of
emails from people who say that they
used to be alright and then I found my
work and they move across I get a lot of
emails from people saying and that they
they are still like don't quite agree
with everything I say but they're
starting to move across after my video
on abortion
actually I got a lot of people who are
pro-life who said that I changed their
mind which was interesting and I might
actually get a lot of emails in
particular from men who are looking for
a new way of being masculine or approach
to being intellectual that isn't
necessarily competitive who say that
they really value that kind of
environment that I create so it's yeah
yeah yeah but it's quite diverse but I
do get a lot of them yeah I took it a
lot of people write to me saying that
I've sort of changed their outlook on
things and sometimes in subtle ways and
sometimes very drastic ways which is
it's always lovely can you talk a little
bit about that what you hear from men so
do I think you said that was interesting
that people get from you they get a
different way of being was it a
different way of being masculine and and
it can just remind me again how you said
that that was interesting you know I do
get a lot of emails from from guys and
people of all genders but especially
guys who say that they're kind of
looking for a way to be masculine that
isn't necessarily competitive or
aggressive and that they find that the
environment I create so it helps them do
that a way to be intellectual again that
isn't about like winning the debate or
like training for the fight but it's
just about sort of exploring it for
their own sake and having a curious
attitude one of the things I've
expressed kind of concern about is okay
so at the 30,000 foot level we or 10,000
meter level for lack of a better term we
have talked about these algorithms that
will often create self-perpetuating
feedback loops where people are sort of
pushed further and further into more and
more extreme content I I believe it
happens more on the right but it could
conceivably happen on both sides of the
political spectrum and we could kind of
have that conversation and then I will
also hear from people much like you who
say that my content was at some point in
their deep programming phase something
that the algorithm suggested and got
them out of whatever ideology they had
initially been pulled into and one of
the things I've said is on an objective
level I think that this is good in that
I think the alt-right is a bad set of
ideas and if someone gets pulled out of
that and they come over to my side
that's good at the same time I have the
concern that there is a level of
malleability to people's values and
politics whereby
by clicking around on YouTube they can
get so pulled to one side and then by
mere chance
algorithmic chance they get dragged all
the way back to the other side even if I
agree with the outcome I'm still
concerned that there is that level of
malleability do you share that concern
and what what's your sort of thought
about that I die I see where you're
coming from I understand the worry and
especially that it seems to be governed
by kind of big technological unseen
forces like the algorithm but at the
same time I think that's absolutely
wonderful and if people can earn and
change their minds and that people
remain curious and that all it takes is
like a little knock on a door you
haven't realized was there and you can
open in me like oh my god I was wrong
the whole time that's one of the
feelings that I love is when you go my
gosh I was completely wrong about this
now I have an opportunity to learn
something wonderful when new and
something I'd never considered about
females I love the most I get in people
when people say I never thought about it
that way or I never thought about it at
all and that's that's wonderful because
then a whole whole new wing opens up in
your mind and so yeah I guess beautiful
I'm that that is a certainly a very
charitable way to describe it and I
think in a lot of cases that that it
does apply and it simply is that way and
there isn't more to it I guess what I'm
thinking of is if I think of myself now
and ten years ago and when I was in high
school or whatever I want to believe
that I was never in a place where by
clicking around on YouTube if I had seen
ben shapiro
and then stefan molyneux and then
whatever that i would have said oh you
know what I never thought about this
this way I'm now an extreme alt-right
nationalist whatever right like if if
that had been possible I think it would
have said something not particularly
positive about me
that I was so ungrounded in my beliefs
that they could have so drastically been
changed I guess that's my concern well I
mean how I almost went down that path
myself years ago I went through a phase
of him I went like a Hitchens Dawkins
atheist phase that was gradually getting
more and more radically right-wing yeah
but also I mean 10 years ago I was I was
what 16 so I mean who really is that
firmly grounded in their beliefs at 16
or indeed at any age that they can't be
persuaded I mean I understand the desire
to
Oh God you know well I'm not I don't
like the idea that I could have gone
down that road but at the same time
there's something quite I think maybe
that speak to that competitive mindset
there actually that's you know I don't
want to think of myself that I could
ever be persuaded by that but I mean ya
know I mean I guess it's a matter of
degree right there's no question I want
to be clear I'm not suggesting that we
should all be completely insulated from
the idea of re-examining our beliefs are
considering some of our conclusions may
have been off but you know I guess I'm
reminded of there's this cultural critic
and arbiter of ideas named Dave Rubin
who you may be familiar with who nearly
at nearly 40 years old had almost a
hundred and eighty degree sort of
political realignment or awakening and
while he insists a lot of his positions
haven't changed like for example he's
for gay marriage it it there's something
about that that if we believe it to be
genuine and not everybody does at that
age to exist in a way that you could so
radically be quote awakened something
about it I find concerning even without
disagreeing with you that being open to
new ideas and re-examining beliefs is of
course something we should we should
encourage I mean I I agree and I also I
see where you come from and saying that
it's concerning I think it's both
concerning and and kind of beautiful at
the same time can you talk a little bit
not to go completely often in that
rabbit hole can you talk a little bit
about is there a political philosophy
that is implicit in most of the sort of
status quo political conversations that
are happening today about neoliberalism
and social democracy or you know if we
look at like the most prevalent
political debates today is there a
philosophical underpinning that you
believe exists there but which most
people have not actually studied in
detail which would be particularly
useful to understand the political
debates that we're having I mean
certainly a lot of the discussions I
have with people that revolve around
political philosophy people tend to come
at it from a liberal capital L liberal
point of view and I understand that in
the u.s. people sometimes use the
differently so in the UK we I would say
that both the major political parties in
your country are capital L liberals even
though one of them is is more
conservative so I think often people
come at it from that from that
perspective and it's sometimes you know
I was raised raised with that
perspective so it's kind of sometimes
difficult to get out from under it and I
find it very interesting and very
rewarding and kind of fun to make people
aware of that perspective and I did this
series a while ago it was quite a few
years ago now called what was liberalism
which which if a lot of people have
written to me saying hi you know I never
thought about it like that which is
quite interesting almost like trying to
step outside of it and look in so I
guess people learning a little bit like
what liberalism is and where it comes
from and how it's not sort of built into
the fabric of the universe but in fact
you can get curious about it and change
if you want to and I find that to be a
particularly rewarding aspect of what I
do what do you think is a is a a
specific alternative to that type of
status quo liberalism using you know
that the word in the sense that you're
talking about that is most interesting
to point people to if they're looking to
explore alternatives I try not to point
people towards a specific tendency or
anything and but like one alternative to
liberalism would be fascism and another
would would I guess be left ISM so I
would say that I'm a leftist and I
deliberately in public don't get any
more specific than that and but
certainly I find that a lot of people a
lot of people reflexively defend
capitalism without really having
necessarily thought about it or
everything that comes along with it and
sometimes it's it's fun to kind of pull
on that thread and think okay where did
you get this idea from and and I
describe it as like dislodging an idea
inside your head and saying where did I
get this and how does it work and do I
want to keep it or not and sometimes
people go yes actually I do know that I
understand that I do wanna hang on to
this and that's fine and sometimes
people go actually you know what this is
kind of weird and what else have you got
there's a couple things that you do that
I'm curious about whether you do them
for a particular strategic reason or
they are merely the way you like to do
things or whatever the case may be one
is that your videos are produced in a
way that includes I'm I'm thinking that
they include scripts and sort of some
pretty specific thought as to what is
said and when sometimes
Toomes and imagery and and things that
sort of go around the edges of the ideas
is that something you do merely because
you enjoy it is there some strategy
behind it I mean speculating the idea
that maybe helps appeal to people that
might be I don't know center-right
gamers that might get pulled in by the
algorithm or whatever the case may be I
mean how much of that is merely what you
like to do versus a strategic decision I
mean it's both so but perhaps for your
viewers who haven't seen any of my
videos I just say I will sometimes
include I use a lot of visual metaphor
these a lot of costumes and characters
and narrative devices in my video about
abortion which we mentioned earlier it
was spliced in with a short film that I
made and and I do all of that again both
I partly because I love it because in my
other life I am a professional actor
Idol I love theater and film and the use
of visual metaphor and telling a story
that way and but it also does help it
does help draw people and people get
excited about it people like it it's
very different
it's something that not a lot of people
can do you know when I started out on
YouTube nobody was summarizing Plato but
now you throw a stone in the woods and
you'll hit 50 youtubers summarizing
Plato right so incorporating all that
stuff is kind of like something that
only that only I can do and so it brings
my unique creative twist to it which I
love and and it does it does help people
learn in different ways because there's
more than one way of skinning the cat
you know sometimes people will say I
don't really get what you mean by and by
Timothy Morton's concept of the hyper
object of climate change and I say well
it's in front of you because that's the
costume I'm wearing it's like a visual
representation of his whole book on this
philosophy so maybe if people find it
hard to engage one way the quote
theatrical stuff can help do it the
other way like I did a video a while ago
honor the philosophy of mind and trauma
and it's all one uncut half-hour
monologue there's no cuts to it and
that's not an accident that's not just
I'm rambling it's very tightly scripted
it's because that is actually designed
to tell you something about what it's
like to learn about trauma and to learn
about these ideas so I do it because I
love it and because it works and because
it's just yeah it's so much fun if it
helps people learn is there a particular
philosophical thought line that you
think is most acutely missing from the
sort of brains of people that are
discussing politics and culture and the
way that society should be
organized where if it was more known to
people we would all be far better off so
like I often talk about how there's such
a lack of critical thinking and sort of
learning how to learn and understanding
how propaganda works and that's like a
set of knowledge that would be very
useful in general for a lot of the
conversations we're trying to have when
it comes to philosophy is there
something in particular that you believe
if more people studied and were
acquainted with we would be much better
positioned to figure out many of the
problems that modern societies deal with
I definitely agree with you about
propaganda and it's it's it's useful to
learn how that works I guess something
that I then I have struggled to find a
way to teach um is not even an idea or a
set of ideas but more like a set of
skills that studying forcibly formerly
brought me which is like how to read and
break down an argument so sometimes I
will get comments under my videos where
people say well what about this thing
this one tiny thing that you said
invalidates everything else and I go
well no because that's actually not
really relevant that was a side comment
or that was an aside or that's not or
actually if you take that out the rest
of it still works so there's something
about argumentative structure and like
logical structure that I have I think
picked up it's it's not not even a
language like almost a grammar of
philosophical arguments which I have
struggled to find a way to teach on its
own and then I'm just always kind of
thinking about which which I think would
maybe be maybe be useful and it's it's
not even like reading comprehension it's
something even more basic like logical
comprehension and like something being
entailed by something else and like how
arguments fit together I think would be
really I I would find it very useful but
then perhaps that's just me not knowing
how to effectively communicate with
people who haven't had that that studied
yeah I mean it is it is a skill in and
of itself how to teach people how to
teach themselves so to speak or to teach
people how to learn and I 100% agree I
mean both in my academic experience and
my media experience it just seems
acutely missing from a lot of the
conversations that that were having
about so many of the most important
issues of the day we've been speaking
with Oliver thorn who is not only a
professional
but also the creator of philosophy tube
on YouTube Oliver so great to speak to
you I really appreciate your time my
pleasure thank you so much out of you
this is so much fun
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
there's a really strange story about how
Donald Trump will just not stop talking
about North Korean dictator Kim jong-un
to other world leaders and the other
world leaders are getting really weirded
out by what Tunnel Trump is doing you
know how sometimes a four-year-old will
be obsessed with telling the same story
over and over again to anyone they talk
to my blue Legos disappeared and I made
a green castle and mommy gave me a
cookie oh that's great that's great
yeah and just telling the same story
over and over again Trump has become the
sort of adult I'm not gonna call it the
adult version of that but sort of the
adult version of that Trump reportedly
going into the same weird monologue
about how wonderful dictator Kim jong-un
is to any world leader that will listen
and we had the g7 last month
we're according to three sources if
there was a meeting with the world
leaders understandably as there were of
course many meetings and the topic of
North Korea actually came up during this
meeting and the context was hey North
Korea has been firing short-range
ballistic missiles into the Sea of Japan
and Trump interjects this tangential
wacky story about just how great Kim
jong-un is and how great Trump's
relationship with Kim Jeong RunAs he
rambled for 10 minutes reportedly and
the room of world leaders was in visibly
stunned silence according to three
people that were in the room funny how
often that happens because yesterday we
learned that at the g7 Trump walked into
a meeting set to be with the Egyptian
president and yelled where is my
favorite dictator also putting the room
into this stunned silence and here it is
this time talking just so positively
about another dictator kim jeong-hoon
now here is where it gets even weirder
Donald Trump has told this exact same
story verbatim before in Canada last
year Trump told this exact same story to
the same group of world leaders - Boris
Johnson Boris Johnson wasn't the British
prime minister at the time so it was a
marginally different group and it's this
story about how you know the little
rocket man stuff got Kim jong-un all
wound up and he mentions Elton John when
he tells the story I mean it sounds like
it
be a Saturday Night Live parody of what
Trump says to world leaders but it's a
literal speech that Donald Trump has now
been telling world leaders for multiple
years and the world leaders that see
Trump up close are understandably
horrified by his behavior and that's
terrible if you care about the image of
the United States around the world you
don't have to be you know a hyper
nationalist to just care if the country
you live in is perceived as being headed
up by a clueless clown and no no offense
to clowns of course but it's a totally
respectable job but it is something that
you can care about merely because you
care about the image of the country you
live in now there is a silver lining
here Trump really likes Kim jong-un and
he's not just saying it in other words
Trump lies so often that when we get
what seems to be corroboration about
something Donald Trump thinks in this
case that he likes Kim jong-un there's
this tiny silver lining in that we found
out Trump actually told the truth the
truth about something the trend is that
when Trump is being honest he often is
saying that he likes a dictator one of
the one of the things Donald Trump and
his presidency has been most honest
about one area where we can believe him
is when he's talking about a dictator or
an authoritarian strongman in glowing
terms that seems to actually be just
honest Donald Trump and the problem of
course is that he's so easy to
manipulate North Korea's Kim family has
been trying to control American
presidents for decades but normally the
American presidents and the people
around them have the diplomatic sense
not to allow these propaganda meetings
with no preconditions because they know
they're only good for North Korea
they're only good for the propaganda
that North Korea will then generate from
these meetings and we get nothing and
much like Trump's been played by the
Russians before he's getting played by
Kim jong-un and it's working to such a
degree that in private he's just glowing
about just how terrific Kim jong-un is
now on Friday we are going to deal with
the question when should a president
meet versus not meet or negotiate with
different people it's an important topic
and it relates to Trump in North Korea
we can't just criticize Trump we need to
lay out a framework for when does
dialogue make sense and when is dialogue
or at least dialogue without
preconditions not the right thing I will
deal with that on the Friday show in
audience questions I have some actual
good news related to the women's March
which has unfortunately become very
toxic and counterproductive as a
movement over the last year or so the
women's March is replacing three
inaugural board members and co-founders
who I've talked about before three
people who have been dogged by endless
problems of marginalizing people who
aren't the right type of intersectional
allegations of anti-semitism
marginalization of Jewish women who want
to be part of the movement and I'm
talking of course about Bob bland Tameka
Mallory and Linda Sarsour Sarsour of
course is now a Bernie Sanders surrogate
I told you that about a week or two ago
something that Bernie should be 110
percent disassociating himself from
maybe this will push him to do that
there will be a new set of 16 board
members coming in including three Jewish
women and a trans woman and a whole
bunch of other people now to be totally
honest this strikes me as too little too
late I the the women's March name at
this point is up quite tarnished the
relationships with historically allied
communities like the Jewish community
one of the forefront civil rights
advocate communities in the United
States historically it may be
irreparably frayed I'm not saying I want
it to be I'm saying it may be I'm glad
that Malory bland and Saur Saur are
going bye-bye but I'm just wondering out
loud not in a rhetorical sense but I'm
just wondering is this an organization
that is going to have a role in the 2020
election because you have a progressive
movement that's more engaged than ever
you have new coalition's of all kinds
that includes a very varied list of
groups that are ready to go and working
on the ground the women's March has been
dogged by these people it's become
extremely divisive and to be honest this
is also it's almost like too friendly
of cutting ties with absolutely toxic
people the three board members have
stepped down it's unclear whether they
were forced or not and seems a little
bit soft the statement that was put out
by the women's March is completely
gushing about the groundbreaking work
and sacrifices towards equal rights
unless of course you don't fit the right
version of intersectionality in which
case you're marginalized and it's also
unclear how much the people that remain
or are replacing them are fans of for
example Louis Farrakhan and the Nation
of Islam milieu with which Saur Saur and
Mallory at least and I'm not sure about
bobland were affiliated with I just
don't know and I don't want to belittle
people when they make the right decision
the right decision is that these three
have no business being part of a group
that claims to be about inclusivity and
a Galit Arianism and all of that no
question about it
at the same time it's hard to see this
and have sort of a renewed enthusiasm
for an organization whose rallies have
become sort of secondary to the internal
conflicts and the discrediting of
potential and actual constituent
activists and it is sad because it
started with at least ideas that are
really good ideas that I that I'm behind
the upside is that I do see the momentum
of the progressive movement having legs
in 2020 that go way beyond the women's
March and that's a great thing the
women's March at this point is not going
to be central to what happens in 2020
it's all of the other progressive
activism which is so widespread at this
point in time and that's a good thing we
don't want a prominent organization to
progressive activism that functions as a
sort of gatekeeper that says well Jewish
women they're not really intersectional
in the way that we want and now the
question is will Bernie Sanders disavow
Linda Sarsour as a surrogate a totally
divisive character she shouldn't be
involved with a good progressive
campaign like the one that bernie is
running and by the way I expected wholly
negative reactions to my segment last
week or the week before saying Linda
Sarsour should not be a Bernie surrogate
there was a little bit of that toxic
left that didn't like it but
overwhelmingly positive overwhelmingly
positive response to that and that that
may have been an area I would have
previously self-censored on so that's
great
the voicemail number for the show is two
one nine to david p here's another song
submitted to the david pakman show take
a listen to this one hello well hello
david it's so nice to have you back on
your youtube show you're lookin swell i
can't
yes very good thank you i don't know if
that is supposed to be made also into a
dubstep EDM remix but at this point the
questions around whether these are
satirical songs or not are only growing
and thank you for the submission i
appreciate it is this may is this the
best singer from our audience so far
that a submitted a song that is my
question to you we've got a great bonus
show for you today four hundred and
fifty thousand people applied for andrew
yang thousand dollar a month offer that
he announced at the presidential debate
last week we will also talk a more about
donald trump looking to turn New Mexico
red and Arizona's Supreme Court has
greenlit discrimination against against
same-sex weddings all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show
I implore you to join me there by
becoming a member at join pakman.com or
a patron at patreon.com slash david
pakman show
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
you